[Musica]
allora io sono medico di okubo di
ricerca ma anche occupato una cosa che
credo sia interesse rete comune nel
cuore l'invecchiamento e particolar modo
di strategie che possano permettere
limitare un rileggere trovando dentro in
maniera ancora più affascinante una
strana longevità
iniziamo con sfatare il mito donna e
qualche modo la caratterizzavano che gli
studi di biologia e medicina
tutto ciò che è biologico non è vero per
i batteri ad esempio ma anche un
organismo complesso e un carro
eucariotica un mammifero potrebbe
evitare l'invecchiamento
esiste un mammifero perfetto modello
ideale a cui potremo tutti aspirare
eccolo certo non è bellissimo devo dire
la verità quello che ho guadagnato in
longevità probabilmente l'ha perso in
estetica si chiama etero safe house
glaber anche il nome non è il massimo
della vita è noto nel mondo della
ricerca della bio gerontologia con il
nome naked morat beh oltre ad essere
super longevo 32 anni e per un ratto è
veramente un età di sopravvivenza enorme
e oltre ad essere completamente immune
da malattie croniche come il cancro il
diabete anche se ci si cerca di indurle
me la cosa più straordinaria forza il
fatto che è affetto si può dire da un
fenomeno chiamato negligible senescence
cioè questo animale non invecchia se
prendi un animale di una mano e uno di
32 anni sono identici da un punto di
vista biochimico e soprattutto del
mantenimento delle funzioni non
entreremo nei segreti biologici
complessi e non completamente compresi
di questo animale ma voglio portarvi un
concetto cioè l'idea
divergente out of the box che è
possibile studiare i segreti per
ottenere un invecchiamento in salute
guardando a modelli positivi invece che
come normalmente fa la medicina
guardando e studiando le malattie e ci
sono oltre a questi strani animali e non
è l'unico dei modelli che appartengono
anche alla specie umana cioè soggetti
che hanno ottenuto in qualche modo un
invecchiamento di successo
mi riferisco ai centenari e in
particolar modo ai semi e ai
supercentenari soggetti che raggiungono
i 105 ei 110 anni e che sono tipicamente
caratterizzati dalla mancanza di
patologie croniche che invece purtroppo
è il modo con cui non conosciamo il
processo di invecchiamento tutti voi
sapete che esistono delle zone del mondo
una in italia in sardegna ad esempio
dove c'è un'alta concentrazione di
questi soggetti che raggiungono una
eccezionale età è un invecchiamento in
salute ma io ho avuto la fortuna di
collaborare molto con il gruppo che
studia invece di farlo in italia i
centenari a sud del giappone
nell'arcipelago di okinawa la prefettura
più a sud del giappone un regno
indipendente fino alla fine del dl
dell'ottocento regno di rue più ed è un
luogo in cui la quantità di centenari in
salute è veramente straordinario
è un posto meraviglioso da un punto di
vista climatico sembra di stare anzi sta
letteralmente ai tropici questo signore
accanto a me a 105 anni quest'altro neve
a 108 era uno dei più anziani ai tempi
adesso credo che non ci sia più quella
accanto a lui e mia moglie
diciamo l'isola di okinawa è
interessantissima da un punto di vista
ambientale e il segreto della longevità
che
in qualche modo è l'obiettivo da
scoprire in soggetti che hanno ottenuto
questo questo questo incredibile
successo dipende da moltissimi fattori
moltissime variabili e la collaborazione
in corso con il gruppo dei ricercatori
che stabilmente vive lì in particolar
modo due gemelli che si chiamano wilcox
sono canadesi ma stato da 30 anni in
giappone ha studiato molto la genetica
di questi soggetti e io mi sono
interessato molto di più agli aspetti
ambientali
sicuramente una delle componenti
interessanti per esempio è il fatto che
durante l'invecchiamento questi soggetti
continuano ad avere una notevole
attività fisica
giravo il luogo dove è stato di fatto
inventato il karate e quando cercato di
insegnarmi qualche mossa questo signore
non aveva ancora 100 anni maniera 98 è
un maestro di karate e non credo di aver
imparato benissimo e altro aspetto
clamoroso è la gioia di vivere e la
capacità di gestire l'invecchiamento con
delle relazioni sociali ben strutturate
all'interno dei villaggi questa signora
che aveva 101 anni quando l'ho
fotografata beh
al di là dell'aspetto guardate gli occhi
esprimono in maniera evidente una gioia
di vivere che sicuramente parte del
segreto della loro longevità però
l'aspetto dove ci spostiamo su un
grafico più scritto e meno fotografico
dove ci siamo maggiormente concentrati è
legato alla possibilità che una delle
variabili ambientali più importanti su
come impatto sulla nostra salute potesse
contenere dei segreti utili a ottenere
un invecchiamento di successo parlo
della dieta dell'alimentazione e questo
è uno dei tanti lavori abbiamo
pubblicato in collaborazione ci siamo
addirittura sforzati di costruire una
piramide alimentare della dieta tipica
di okinawa
estrapolando dei punti che potessero
essere importantissimi nell'innescare un
invecchiamento di successo sicuramente
un'alimentazione caratterizzata da basso
quantitativo di calorie e dalla presenza
di zuccheri a basso indice glicemico che
non alzano molto i livelli dell'insulina
ma poi le caratteristiche più
interessanti
sono la grande quantità di sostanze
specifiche che lentamente abbiamo
iniziato ad accostare a potenziali
vantaggi sulla salute soprattutto in
un'ottica di un invecchiamento in salute
e alcune di queste sostanze sembrano
molto misteriose
una è nota perché diciamo la curcumina e
un polifenolo contenuto nel numerico la
radice della curcuma longa
ma è la base culinaria del curry una
spezia
un bilancio utilizzatissimo in tutto il
mondo quella è una patata addirittura
protetta siena benino ed è ricca di
antocianine gli abitanti di okinawa anno
il 20 per cento della loro dieta
caratterizzata dall assunzione di alghe
marine è una caratteristica dovuta alla
povertà non è una scelta gustativa
beh di fatto tutte queste sostanze
contengono al loro interno
interessantissimi composti che
appartengono al mondo dei metaboliti
secondari delle piante sostanze che non
fanno parte della nostra biochimica ma
che ora sappiamo sono in grado di
innescare processi molto utili alla
longevità
noi abbiamo utilizzato le informazioni
derivate dalla dall'osservazione di
queste popolazioni per estrapolare
queste sostanze volte anche modificarle
sviluppando brevetti e sperimentarle
prima su modelli animali o cellulari per
animali e poi addirittura sull'uomo
possibilmente lo mosa molisano con
piccoli studi di tipo nutrizionale
l'idea che la nutrizione si rifaccia
modelli positivi
è solamente un tema collegato ai
centenari
anzi la storia della nutrizione devo
dire la stessa dieta mediterranea nasce
dall'osservazione di potenziali vantaggi
di un certo tipo di alimentazione
nell'ambito dei singoli composti un caso
famosissimo e quello degli inuit una
popolazione che non mangia frutta e
verdura ma non ha problemi
cardiovascolari
questo tipo di caratteristica questo
paradosso è stato associato alla loro
abitudine di mangiare moltissimi grassi
derivati dagli animali dei mari freddi e
questo tipo di studi ha portato alla
scoperta degli omega 3 che sono acidi
grassi polinsaturi essenziali quindi di
cui non possiamo fare a meno e che oggi
sappiamo è addirittura hanno avuto
riconoscimenti in termini di indicazioni
salutistiche anche dalla comunità
europea essere fondamentali per la
salute del cuore del cervello
se questa è una storia famosa anche se
ha avuto diciamo ci sono molti dibattiti
ancora sulla sua stretta validità
scientifica
questa è una storia meno famosa ma da un
punto di vista del concetto di modello
positivo nutrizionale è molto più solida
e una piccola etnia gli indios kuna che
vivono in un arcipelago a nord di panama
le isole san blas bene il professor
fallen berg dell'università di harvard
che a cui piacevano queste isole per
motivi turistici lui era un cardiologo
si rese conto che gli abitanti di queste
isole erano virtualmente privi di eventi
ischemici sia di stroke e di infarti e
di demenza e soprattutto erano tutti
ipotesi ci avevano una bassa pressione
sanguigna al contrario degli abitanti di
panama delle stesse etnie che erano
tutti ipertesi associò lentamente questa
strana situazione all'abitudine di
queste popolazioni di assumere
tantissime noci di cacao utilizzavano il
cacao non come fonte di cioccolato
facciamo noi ma al posto del caffè per
fare una bevanda amara il cacao contiene
tantissime sostanze polifenoliche come
quelle che vi ho fatto vedere prima e in
particolar modo un gruppo di polifenoli
si chiamano flavanoli
e in particolar modo le di catechina un
monomero bene questo sono io non sono le
san blas purtroppo ma comunque un bel
posticino sono la zona caffettiera us in
colombia abbiamo avviato una
collaborazione molto intensa negli
ultimi cinque anni con una università
finanziata da una fondazione del cacao e
abbiamo identificato una cultivar di
cacao che produce delle noci ad
altissimo contenuto di flavanoli e di
epicatechina e utilizzando queste
sostanze che abbiamo anche brevettato
abbiamo sviluppato tantissimi studi
prima sperimentali e poi nutrizionali
dimostrando che queste sostanze non solo
come aveva scoperto o lemberg hanno un
effetto molto positivo sul circolo
sanguigno di nuovo indicazione
salutistica che è stata in qualche modo
attribuita dall'europa ai polifenoli del
cacao ma sono in grado anche di
migliorare l'equilibrio lipidico di
ridurre il colesterolo cattivo e
aumentare quello buono e soprattutto di
ottimizzare aspetti collegati a
infiammazione e stress ossidativo né per
nelle persone questa è un'altra storia
di modelli positivi di nutrizione ancora
meno nota è una piccola etnia che vive
in patagonia piccola relativamente ora
sono rimasti in 600mila si chiamano
mapuche sono ancora noti perché sono dei
guerrieri nati e ancora oggi combattono
contro il governo cileno è l'unica
popolazione del sud america che non è
mai stata conquistata né dagli incas
quindi dagli stessi sudamericani antichi
né dai conquistadores dei veri guerrieri
bene il segreto della loro stamina della
loro energia e della loro salute era
legato a un fermentato che si chiama
ciccia ed è un fermentato di una sorta
di mirtillo che vive che cresce solo
nelle zone del sud del cile della
patagonia
si chiama aristotelici lenses amati ed è
in fondo un super mirtillo cioè
esattamente come il mirtillo contiene
tantissimi polifenoli della famiglia
delle antocianine
ma ha una concentrazione incredibilmente
elevata anche in questo caso come come
avrete capito mi piace molto viaggiare e
nonostante mi occupi di biochimica
nostro un vero topo di laboratorio
questa è una spedizione abbiamo iniziato
una collaborazione con l'università di
valdivia che all'inizio della patagonia
per studiare le proprietà di questo
mirtillo e anche in questo caso abbiamo
sviluppato tantissimi studi nutrizionali
poi sviluppati qui in molise su persone
sovrappeso ma tendenzialmente sane
dimostrando di nuovo un effetto molto
positivo soltanto i biomarcatori
collegati a un invecchiamento in salute
questi sono degli esempi abbiamo fatto
una breve carrellata non si poteva
esaurirli tutti ho cercato di farvi
vedere delle cose un po affascinanti
anche da un punto di vista antropologico
però da tutto a questa carrellata vorrei
estrapolare un messaggio e del vero
messaggio out of the box in un contesto
di divergenza dalla scienza classica il
messaggio è questo
quando ne parliamo di alimentazione
salutistica di dieta salubre il nostro
concetto è sempre
stiamo attenti alle cose che ci fanno
male eliminiamo i grassi carboidrati
tutto ciò che in qualche modo è dannoso
beh c'è un pensiero secondo me è molto
più forte ed è un pensiero che abbiamo
battezzato nel circolo di chi si occupa
di questi modelli positivi nutrition
non preoccupiamoci solo di eliminare le
cose che fanno male ma preoccupiamoci di
inserire ogni giorno le cose che ci
fanno bene questo è un messaggio molto
positivo in un'ottica addirittura di
disturbi del comportamento alimentare
causati dalle diete ma anche in
un'ottica di intervento reale sulla
possibilità di gestire la salute
estremamente promettente vi ringrazio